i wrote a book a couple years ago on how
to engage with leftists with basically
how to how to defeat them it's called
how to topple the left's house of cards
um my viewpoints have actually changed
just a little bit not on political
policy since then but at the time that i
wrote that it was published in 2017 i
thought okay people need to learn how to
actually engage it's such an
intimidating thing right to
talk to liberal friends or liberal
family or people at your college
and not know what to say not have the
exact response for a specific talking
point from the left and i thought well i
work in this business i know all of the
answers to that let me write a handbook
or a manual so that people can learn how
to do that too
and it's not that i reject that
viewpoint now i've just realized that
given the ideology that is so pervasive
on the left right now this this very
marxist ideology whether it's critical
race theory whether it's the transgender
ideology um 1619 project this this
anti-american attitude coming from the
left that we actually can't always
change people's minds call this cynicism
that's come with age but we can't
necessarily change people's minds but
what we can do is we can enact policies
that stop the creation of new leftists
meaning stop people from being
indoctrinated into marxism and so that
that has resonated in such an
interesting way with young people on
college campuses to hear like oh i might
not be able to change this this crazy
professor's viewpoint but i can actually
do things at the state or local level
that stop his viewpoint being taught to
children or stop his viewpoint being
applied to me so that's what i've been
uh spending the last semester doing
talking to college college students
about about that and you know just
diving into this this new media that
we're all doing what what what are you
hearing when you go talk to college
students what do you like and i'm not
talking about people that agree with you
because people who agree with you it is
what it is there's no converting there's
people that
don't agree with you that are open to
receiving what are you noticing with
them yeah i mean they immediately appeal
to
kindness and compassion or how they
define kindness and compassion so one of
the most common questions that i get
from
leftists is oh i have a transgender
friend or i have a transgender classmate
and i don't want to deny their dignity i
don't want to deny their personhood i
don't want to anger them by not calling
them by the pronouns that they choose or
not acknowledging what they're suffering
and that's a very valid i mean that's a
very is that the most common response
that it has to do with trans
pronunciation of their
how they identify that's the most common
thing you hear literally the most common
thing that i hear from college age
liberals is you are not being kind to
transgender i am just trying to be kind
to these people because these people i
mean the narrative is that they're
bullied the narrative is that they
commit suicide at very high rates which
is true on both accounts um and these
college kids want to know you know why i
don't support
their transition
because they these students believe that
the transition is actually being helpful
to the students you have 100
conversations how many times does the
trans stuff come up with these people as
the first thing they bring up a lot
really like 50 80 that's insane that's
crazy because
it's like a heavy topic right yeah
go back and think when you and i were in
high school that was a long time ago
right 24 years ago we were 25 years ago
we were in high school there was no cell
phones right for me 25 years for you 23
years there was no cell phones there was
no social media there was no facebook
there was none of that stuff so that's
what they're seeing every day so they're
seeing those videos going viral that's
the topic they're seeing the controversy
chapel stuff
they're on the caitlyn jenners of the
world you're not nice you're not you
know you're too disrespectful yet people
be why don't you accept and that's
that's the conversation they're probably
going through there's a difference
between like what's being seen and the
reality that that gets so such a
non-issue for
percent of americans but you gotta work
on the campus the campuses well it's
it's a good part of human nature though
to want to be a voice for the voiceless
or to want to stand up for the
marginalized so i don't discourage that
i just i encourage the the college
students to actually define well what is
compassion what does it mean to actually
help these people what does it mean to
give them dignity and respect because we
should treat everyone with dignity and
respect and fight for equality under the
law but it's not compassionate to push
them into a surgery that they're gonna
regret that's irrevocable it's not
compassionate to indulge delusion that's
that's not compassion that's actually
the opposite that's that's a form of
abuse you have trans friends yeah you do
and how do you have those conversations
with them my trans friends tend to be
conservative
conservative trans friends yeah
yeah they give an example give an
example of one chad felix green
chad felix green and what's the
conversation with him or to you know
chad being transgender what's
his uh approach towards politics versus
others he's very much against the
transgender ideology as it as it
pertains to our current political topic
he understands that he suffers from
gender dysphoria that's a real thing
it's a mental health issue he
understands that he suffers from that
and that it causes him to want to
mutilate his body and he resists that he
know he understands that you know he was
guided a lot by walt heyer i don't know
if you're familiar with walt heyer walt
heyer is probably 65 70 years old right
now transition was born biologically
male transitioned to a woman spent 20
years as a quote unquote woman and then
detransitioned because of regret and now
helps young people who are suffering
from gender dysphoria either
detransition or
cope how you should with the mental
health issue so chad still identifies as
i mean he says he's transgender he says
he suffers from gender dysphoria but he
doesn't he didn't undergo surgery
yeah i think
the biggest thing is the fact that you
can't have the conversation you can't
challenge you can't push somebody's
uh uh you know whatever argument they
may be having that's the issue but but
it's great to see somebody like you i
think
you're doing it charlie's doing it few
people are doing it that are going on
campuses and it's creating a ruckus i
mean it's getting what have you had an
experience where they wanted to kick you
off campus has that happened to you yet
or no um are they pretty friendly to you
well no they're not friendly to me so
what what typically happens or what
happened i'm trying to think of what
college this was i think it was at the
university of michigan we went to the
university of michigan late last fall
and you know they put posters up the yaf
students young americans foundation
students that host me on the campuses
put posters up for the events all over
and they they plastered probably a
thousand of them all over the walls just
to make a show and then they caught on
video leftists who are ripping them down
one by one and throwing them in the
trash can
um there's been a really interesting
change though on college campuses five
years ago if you went to a college
campus and
talked about a controversial issue a lot
of people would turn out who didn't
agree with you
it was in fact i mean you've everyone's
seen those video clips where the
leftists is getting squashed by some um
owned if you will by some conservative
speaker and they wanted to engage they
thought like listen my arguments will
get the best of you they wanted to have
that engagement
um
they don't they don't come anymore they
don't come any more the same way i mean
since since the advent of cancel culture
since the advent of these safe spaces
and trigger warnings and everything they
typically just go outside and protest
and they don't want you to be allowed to
be there versus engagement
so you're saying they're trying to
cancel you they don't even want you on
campus versus coming and debating you
and engaging you and having yeah i
always invite them i actually i actually
always say before i go anybody who
disagrees with me my producers will
bring you to the front of the line at
the question and answer like i want to
engage are you speaking at a podium are
you just going out and and no no these
are confusing
no no it's not man on the street it's an
event a hosted event where you know
hundreds of people come and it's in an
auditorium generally um just like a lot
of other speakers i mean it's a it's a
very common thing that happens in
college campuses different clubs bring
in different speakers
yeah but but i love that though i love
anything having to do with debate i love
it i love your courage to go out there
and have those conversations we need
way more people who have the courage
like you to go out there and talk people
especially
opposition to talk to these younger kids
go ahead tom you know what's really
interesting is is
my wife the biz doc babe
she teaches seventh eighth grade and
kids are coming in with the notion that
to disagree remember there's disgust
process and then open conflict now open
conflict is disrespectful yelling back
and forth but processing the kids don't
feel that processing is polite or nice
well that wouldn't be nice that wouldn't
be polite so you've got kids there in
the formative years sixth seventh eighth
going into middle school about to be
teenagers where the emotions kick in and
they are sort of being indoctrinated by
a system that says don't process because
that wouldn't be nice and that elevates
to in high school well you don't have
the right to question someone else i'm
not questioning i just want to process
something that's of social importance or
something that i think maybe we can both
learn from suddenly you go from nice to
right to cancel and that's the flow
exactly what you just brought up pat and
it's happening i think that's the worst
part of it because what we're seeing is
the downstream issue downstream issue
pollution happens upstream downstream
the lake is polluted and we look at it
and go gosh how do we fix this the
upstream problem is these kids won't
aren't even being taught how to have a
civil processing discussion so if you
enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]